I'm gonna thank everyone for coming I'm
les and the director of engineering at
quarter Co we're a non-profit production
arm embedded within the lab for social
machines at the MIT Media Lab which is
kind of like a stacking ball of
different orgs but I'd be happy to talk
more about this later if people are
interested so today I'll be talking
about a topic detection system that we
built to find local events of interest
in Twitter and other sources of data and
a note on the title of the talk this
isn't a theoretical thing that we came
up with and wrote a bunch of papers to
prove that it's optimal this is actually
a production system that we built built
that's that's fast and it gives us
reasonable interpret all results but you
know that's said I'm going to go with
with the Fineman admonishment that I
should bend over backwards to show you
how the system doesn't work well you
know as well as how it does work so okay
so just to get some contact so core Koza
is a is is a nonprofit inside of the
Media Lab and the goal of the group is
to foster a healthy public sphere which
is admittedly nice and grand sounding
kind of vague on the details of what
that actually means you know so we we
take inspiration from from from harbor
masses definition of the public sphere
where there are three components there
are people the media and institutions
people represent individual voices for
it like given me institutions are
typically groups of people but it could
be celebrities um but it's generally
it's a group of people who have some
sort of coercive power on people who are
in the out-group so you think for
instance government or private
corporations but it could also be
smaller entities like your Neighborhood
Association or your School PTA and then
the media is the place by which we
transmit ideas that we can debate so
that the institutions can be checked but
also so that the institutions can
understand the needs of the people so
these these ideas or things which we can
debate is really the core motivation for
the technology that we're building that
I'll be describing today and we call
these things which we can debate events
because they tend to be temporal in
nature like someone gets
elected or something of really local
interest happens like you know bears are
spotted roaming in a neighborhood and we
called these we you know we call our
system and event detection system so
that we can distinguish between it and
more coarse-grained persistent topics so
that event might be a particular thing
like some erratic president tweets but a
topic might be something persistent like
like politics okay though we ingest
multiple types of data the two that we
actually surfaced at the moment to our
users or talk radio and Twitter and we
process a couple million tweets per day
and thousands of hours of talk radio per
day runs through our custom speech
detect system and our talk radio corpus
is we believe the largest of its kind
that has ever existed and so this talk
really focuses on event detection in
Twitter and for reasons that I'll talk
about later why doesn't work so well
with talk radio so I just want to give
you a quick glimpse of one of our
products so you get an idea of what it
is that we're after so the this this
thing is called ear shot it's a tool
that we faced towards journalists so
they can better understand what's
happening in their communities we grab
talk radio and data and tweets and we
throw it into an index that's searchable
in various ways from this interface this
this one screen and journalists have can
take out local stories of you know of
interest on and if they have they've
like they've written stories on this and
in one case they even broke a story
about a campaign finance violation in
Rhode Island using the data as far as we
know is only available to us so on this
screen you can see Twitter clustering
and this is off of our discover page
then each of these events is
automatically generated and we show
representative words for some cluster
I'm sorry is the I just noticed that the
other resolution is saying looks
terrible so I don't know if you'll be
able to read anything but so totally
have words I represent the each each
cluster as well as what we call a
representative tweet all right I hope I
hope the legibility is not an issue okay
so what are we working with so cordial
has
developed a method for geo ranging
tweets so this is roughly saying okay
based off a set of local influencers
institutions like schools museums
municipal services politicians local
celebrities we can infer if a particular
account often interacts with influencers
or not and if so then we say that
they're there gee arranged to that area
I won't get again into exactly how this
works but the end result is that we have
a collection of tweets streams one
proceeding in the US that we service
so roughly roughly a dozen at the moment
we stream these tweets which end up in
s3 and then on a per hour basis we load
up the trailing 24 hours of tweets and
run our system on that and the contents
of each one of these tweet files looks
like this if you've ever worked with
Twitter data before you've probably seen
something like this it's a big mess of
JSON so a tweet object contains a lot of
data from the tweet body to the metadata
such as the name of the person tweeting
information about the account of the
person their follower account their
following account and there are a
variety of ways that you might be able
to use this data but you know like you
could for instance overweight people
with lots of followers on so what they
say becomes more important but for our
system we don't do anything like that we
basically just throw out everything
except for just the content of the tweet
okay so just to restate what I said we
only look at the tweet body and so we
extract just a content of the tweet we
do note if if this thing was an original
post or retweet okay so where do we go
from here we'd like to bring these
tweets together into related clusters
and there are a variety of techniques
for doing this which I'll give a very
very fast tour through then I'll talk
about how we don't use any of these
things at all
so k-means k-means is is perhaps the
most well known clustering technique we
start with an assumption that we have
our tweets located in some space where
we can calculate a distance between them
and then that will be finding K clusters
then we'll go through a process of
figuring out what this clusters are and
refining them over and over again so the
first thing we do is we pick K random
tweets as our first K clusters all right
and then we we look at all of the other
tweets and we sign them to the clusters
that they're closest to so now each
cluster gets just a little bit bigger
alright and we can take that class here
and we can recompute its center and then
repeat the process take all the tweets
again reassign them to to the new
locations that they might be closest to
which change the shapes of the clusters
again we just keep doing this over and
over again until until the clusters
converge and we aren't reassigning these
tweets anymore and once that's happened
we're done l da LD is maybe the
workhorse of these kinds of topic
modeling techniques LD is interesting it
makes a few assumptions so the first
assumption that it makes is that a topic
is the distribution of words so a pets
topic for instance might be well
represented by the words dog and cat but
not at all by the word asparagus the
second is that a document is a mix of
topics so a document might mostly be
about pets
but it might also be about veggies and
then the combination of these two
assumptions gives you a way to model a
collection of tweets so so in other
words you can use some definition of
topics X words and generate a new set of
tweets that statistically look like real
world tweets they'd actually look like
nonsense Lda throws out a lot of
information about the structure of the
language and just looks at collections
of words as if they were you know I you
know just a physics but you know but
that's fine because it fulfills all the
properties I didn't need for for further
clustering stuff later okay so that's
that's how you get tweets from topics
but actually we like to go the other way
around and get topic from tweets so how
do we do that so we do something that's
kind of like k-means so we start with K
empty topics and we go through every
word in every tweet and we randomly
assign it to one of these topics
so now we have a set of really terrible
topic models and we'd like to refine it
so then we go through each word of every
tweet again and we say okay which one of
these topics most likely produced this
word and we update that words assignment
to its new topic so the topics get just
a little bit better right and we keep
doing that again and again and again
until it converges in the same ways
k-means so there's a really neat thing
that comes out of LD a actually which is
that you get these word distributions
that represent the models and these tend
to be a much easier way for us to
interpret the the output in the case of
k-means we just got clusters of tweets
and then you would have to read through
them and try to figure out in some way
what that cluster is about with Lda you
get the important words that define each
topic so this is a thing that we'd like
to have if possible non-negative matrix
factorization so this is the the cool
kid on the block right now I I actually
haven't personally met anybody who's
used this thing but I like read stuff
about how it's so great so I can't
really comment on the quality of the
output or what it's like like actually
implementing this thing but it's you
know we get is something that
researchers are excited about as I think
it's I'm not totally sure but as far as
I know I think it's in it's in pretty
pretty major you send out flicks in
Spotify
so the basic intuition is this okay
suppose we set up the matrix we're on
one dimension we have all of the tweets
and on the other dimension we have all
the words so we can fill in the matrix
with values that we know so like if for
this example so tweet tweet one let's
say it contains word number two so we so
we mark a one there and then tweet two
contains word number one and word number
three so we mark ones there and tweet
three contains words three and four so
we put marks there you know just imagine
in an actual corpus this thing is much
much larger so you can take this matrix
and you can factor it into two smaller
matrices with some intermediate with K
you'll see K is this this kind of
reoccurring thing that's happening with
all these algorithms um but in this
unders example here I've just I've just
made this simple when I clicked the cave
to
you know yen like in the real world you
would have much much larger matrices
much much larger values what nmf does
then is the generates these two factors
of the larger matrix right such that the
k's represent a kind of hidden latent
structure so in the case of the top
matrix we have tweets i would assign be
assigned to topics k1 and k2 and then in
the case of the bottom matrix we have
words assigned to the topics k1 and k2
right so we get a description of the
topic to which is nice and the way that
nmf does this is using a well-known
mathematical process called magic all
right okay so now we have a few general
techniques under our belt how do we
actually set up our data I'm only going
to give an example for the k-means case
and for that we just need to be able to
say how far away two tweets are from
each other so there are a few methods
for doing this but most require being
able to place the document into some
kind of a vector space that's beyond the
scope of this talk so instead I'll just
show how we can use something called
that your card index to do this okay so
this is the card index so suppose we
have we have two documents here and our
first document is me before Strange Loop
I'm not a real programmer unless I know
how school these are this is actually a
tweet from last year uh-huh our second
document is me after Strange Loop I'm
not a real programmer unless I knit
I think someone had like given a talk
about programming looms this to me just
kind of epitomizes what strange loop is
about so the jacquard index is the size
of the union of all the turns in these
two in these two documents so if we keep
it simple and we just say okay so the
term for the documents are just
whitespace broken up tokens and in
sentences
our first document becomes strange loop
haskell i i'm me a before no.not
programmer rule unless and our second
document is strange loop I I me a after
knit not programmer real unless and in
the intersection of the two is just
which words overlap strange loop I I'm
EA not programmer real unless and the
size of that thing is 9 so that's that's
that's that's the
the values of jacquard index and that's
a pretty high index because it's pretty
close to the length of the actual
sentences so in contrast some document
estranged loop is a cyclic structure
that goes through several levels in a
hierarchical system hesita card in the
index of just two with the other two
sentences the words a and Strange Loop
are the overlapping words so if we're
lucky that the jacquard index will give
us a rough quantitative notion of how
similar two documents are and that gives
us enough information they plug into
k-means so that it can do its thing
so the k-means um we still have the
problem of being able to recompute
centroids which the jacquard index
doesn't make that very easy but the way
that we can do that is for every every
cluster that we have sorry when we want
to recompute it centrally we can pick a
representative document in that cluster
and then pick the entire set such that
they're all as dissimilar as possible so
there's a problem though which is that
things get a bit dicey here with very
short documents so in this example tweed
a they're good dogs print and tweet B
they're bad cats Sally so there's
clearly some relationship between the
tweets but the jacquard index or any
distance metric that looks at just the
words in these two documents doesn't
fully capture it so the only overlapping
word here is there but the structure of
the sentence is similar alright and
what's more the the type of the words
good and bad are the same the type of
the words dog and cats the same the type
of Brenton Sally is the same as well so
we have a case where we'd like to be
able to infer the similarity and these
documents with a pretty low a low amount
of information and in fact if you
consider a really degenerate case you
want to be able to determine that these
two tweets might actually be talking
about the same thing but there's zero
information in the documents themselves
that might actually tell you this so you
might be thinking yeah you know that
sucks for k-means but what about one of
the other methods they all suffer from
similar issues like this so with with LD
a in particular and I'm thinking on that
one because it's actually it's a popular
one all right
yeah you know it it models these these
documents as mixtures of topics but
there isn't with just one word in the
document there isn't much that you can
really say about the mixture of anything
okay so how do we as humans know that
dogs and cats are related we know these
things might be related because when we
talk about them we talk about them in
the same way so computationally what we
can do is we can look at their word
co-occurrences so in other words yeah
right so we can look at the other words
that they appear that appear in there in
these contacts contacts hmm so you might
say the word dogs sits somewhere near
pet similarly the word cat also sits
somewhere near pet and so sentences
about dogs and cats are related via the
word pets you can in effect amplify the
information within a very short document
by looking at that word similarity to
other words in a in a broader context so
one way to the quantitatively capture
how near each other they are would be to
calculate some kind of a distance
between these co-occurring words and we
do have useful techniques for doing this
the most popular would be something like
worth of Act which uses a neural net to
embed these things into the vector space
and then you can use just a desire boat
to calculate some distance something
else that you might do is you know
figure okay how well well so how many
sentences contain both of these words if
cats and dogs never show up in the same
sentence but they do both frequently
co-occur with the word pets right how
many hops does it take to get from cats
to dogs one hop is pretty close by but
if it's a hundred hops away maybe those
things don't have anything to do with
each other so so this is the the this is
the intuition for our method so we
construct this graph structure right
where the nodes are the words and the
edges are occurrences of two words in
the same context as in the case of this
system we define the context is simply
being in the same tweet we have waste on
the edges to write so the more that two
words co-occur than the heavier the
edges and in fact the edges are
basically lists of tweets that contain
two words or nodes in the edge so so in
this example we have an edge between
good and there because both those words
appear in the same tweet similarly we
have
between bad in there because they were
also in the same tweet and let's say in
some other tweet in some other
conversation that I haven't shown here
someone has said something about dogs
and cats as pets so we have we have we
we also have edges from dogs and cats to
pets as well as we establish more and
more of these contacts the edges become
heavier and the relationship between
pets dogs and cats strengthens possibly
faster than the relationship between
good and bad in there and with more and
more contacts and in in fact the words
their branches out quite a bit more and
it hits a larger variety of co-occurring
word nodes compared to pets so another
way to put this is out words that are
low in information might be associated
with a large variety of other words so
they branch out a lot but words that are
tightly related may be don't branch out
so much but have very heavy branches
okay so words that are commonly used in
the same context your cluster together
or form communities of nodes if we
generate this word connection graph then
we can look for these communities of
nodes using a community detection
algorithm and possibly tease out the
topics so the algorithm that we use is
it's called levain and it has a bit of
historical use in previous quartic oh
and love for social machines research so
so that influence it's a it's it's a
it's choice you know for this uh
for this system levain is in a class of
algorithms that optimizes the thing
called modularity so what is modularity
so let's let's suppose we've got some
algorithm like levain that takes a guess
as to what the communities are so the
question we should ask is okay how how
can we quantify how good this labeling
is on modularity is a metric that
encapsulates two different ideas so the
first idea is okay how many edges reside
in the communities so intuitively we say
a community is is a structure in which
the nodes it's there there it's very
dense there are a lot of
interconnections between nodes and two
different communities don't have a lot
of edges in common they might have some
you know but not a whole lot if they had
a lot of edges in common perhaps they
should all be one
community so so we can take conduction
we can say all right the the fraction of
the edges that sit inside of the
communities should be as close to one as
possible this means most of the edges
are in communities and a very small
amount of edges are between communities
okay so that's principle number one
protocol number two is how unique are
these communities to this graph so in
the in the extreme case where our
community detection algorithm produces
just a single all encompassing community
so just like one label for everything
you know that wouldn't be very useful
for us right so so in other words that
community labeling isn't very unique to
any particular graph since it applies to
all graphs right it doesn't tell us
anything special about this particular
graph versus anything else if we just
say okay everyone is in one group so in
in my opinion this is this last point is
actually the the hardest one of the two
to think about but consider this okay
let's let's say that we have a graph
with labeled communities then we go in
and we mess with a bunch of edges let's
say we randomly swap a ton of the edges
if the community still makes sense then
maybe those community labels weren't
very interesting at all right they just
kind of generically apply to any kind of
a network so what we want here is we
want some metric right we want a large
number of edges to be included in the
communities but we also want a very
unique set of labels such that if you
mess with the graph then the labels no
longer make sense so more precisely
modularity of graph is defined to be the
fraction of edges in communities minus
the expected fraction of edges in those
same communities in a randomly perturb
graph the larger the more of the edges
reside in the communities and a stronger
more unique the labels are modularity
optimization then is an algorithm that
tries to optimize modularity I hope that
makes sense um so given some graph right
we'd like to be able to assign the nodes
into communities such that we get the
largest of the largest modularity value
we can and calculating the optimal set
of labels here is actually an np-hard
problem so we
so we use approximation algorithms for
this so how does the vein work Luo vein
is a greedy algorithm in a consist of
two steps that we that we repeat over
and over again so the first of the first
is that we initialize a state by putting
every node in its own community so you
can see in the initial state right
that's the graph in the lower left then
for each node we ask ok can we increase
the modularity by reassigning this node
to one of its neighboring communities if
so we'll move it otherwise we'll leave
it alone and after this phase so that's
the the top graph right you'll see that
some of these nodes have been have been
labeled so the new communities here are
coated in red green dark blue and light
blue it's a little hard to tell okay so
that's phase one so then for phase two
what we do is we take we take this and
we create a new graph by collapsing all
of those communities into single nodes
so now we have a new graph a new
structure and then we can repeat the
phase one on that and and we just keep
doing this over and over again just
trying to increase the modularity with
every new assignment once we can no
longer increase the modularity we're
done so apply to our word graphs we get
communities of words that show up in
similar contexts often and those tend to
form topics or events so some things
that we had to deal with in practice
levain runs are determined by the size
of the graph so limiting the size
actually goes a long way towards making
things fast so the first thing to note
is a very densely connected words tend
to be pretty low information and these
are words that have the largest number
of edges coming out of them so we do do
a pre filtering step where we cut out
the stop words but the generally
accepted list of stop words is pretty
small these densely connected words are
not they're not stop words right so as
an example these are the words that come
from a run of the algorithm over a day
of tweets arranged to the Boston area
and we cut all these words out
now there's an interesting question here
so what happens to a word like Elizabeth
which in this case appears because of
tweets about Elizabeth Warren who's a
Massachusetts senator so in a topic
detection system it might seem crazy to
cut out the word Elizabeth because
surely like she must contribute some
sort of weight somewhere in them half
but it turns out actually that in in
practice if you cut her name out or you
know or word like Trump it actually
doesn't seem to affect the quality of
the clusters and it's because the the
co-occurring language also has some kind
of a significant pattern to it though
the co-occurring words around her name
or around Trump so it's the case that
the words people are using to describe
some event involving Elizabeth Warren
stick around even though her name might
actually get cut and in a way it's ads
of these communities are even more
robust because you can actually you can
actually remove the centroid and still
see the community there now a really
important thing to point out is that
Levein doesn't require you to specify a
fixed K number of topics beforehand so
this is really really key because you
would expect that the number of things
of interest to not remain constant over
time so the second thing that we do
after cutting out all these dense nodes
is that we restrict the overall size of
the graph so I played around with
different graph sizes starting with
large numbers and trying smaller and
smaller ones and at some point the
clusters become relatively stable but
the process was you know I was just like
me like putting my finger in the air
like it wasn't really a very rigorous at
all um we also eliminate edges that have
weight one ie two words that Kocher in
exactly one tweet and here are some
examples of that so these are our pairs
that are only showing up once per day
it's a bit less clear exactly how we
interpret this they seem to maybe have
some information but you know but again
it doesn't it doesn't seem to adversely
affect the results okay so here's the
final algorithm so we define word
co-occurrence so in this case we're
saying two words in the same tweet are
co-occurring we construct the graph were
words are nodes and the edges are
co-occurrence relationships
we filter out low information words by
high frequency low pairings we pick the
heaviest edges and then we run community
detection on it so I've written this in
a slightly abstract way where you can
swap out methods for number one and five
you know but the general structure we
haven't really changed okay so that's
enough to your rising is the proof in
the pudding said so this is for a run
over one day of Boston data so here we
have a list of the most connected words
are the ones that our system drops from
analysis so this is the output for the
first cluster here we're outputting the
top 20 words in the cluster by true Qin
C of use the counts next to the word are
the number of times that the word shows
up in the in the entire collection of
tweets and you can see that the
distribution of words this in this case
drops off about halfway through and the
tweet that's displayed is a magenta to
tweet for the cluster and I'll go into
how we figured that one out later this
is the output for the second cluster and
this again is Elizabeth Warren related
this science is specifically about her
opponent Jeff deal this representative
tweet I think actually fails to capture
what the cluster here is about I think
or I either got or maybe the clusters a
little too mushy for us to actually have
a good tweet traffic alerts always show
up you know as you might expect with an
event director there drawing from local
data one really important thing to note
about the system is is a limitation I'll
talk a little bit about later is that
the cluster definitions are mutually
exclusive so for instance the word
traffic can only show up in one cluster
so as a result we don't tend to to get
more than one traffic topic unless
there's a major incident like a car
accident in which case the word code
currents distribution around the car
accident looks different than normal
traffic conditions here we have in we
have an area under Presley tweet Presley
had a surprise the victory
in Boston to become the Democratic
nominee for the house much like
Alexandria
Acacio Cortez did in New York and the
Presley victory occurred four days
before this data set anything of real
local interests disabled cruise ship in
Buzzards Bay
I think they survive they have food on
the ship right okay so so does turn out
that we pick up a lot of stories of
strong national interest though that
that though that that particular data
said I showed is still slanted towards
the Boston Talk
one of the reasons here is that the
initial run here we we count retweets
and the system tends to pick up language
around the most popular tweets though
not always and if we discount retweets
then we pick up much more local stories
without retweets the first couple of
clusters are the same they're about
traffic and Elizabeth Warren the next
few clusters are are bit different and
they appear to be more hyper local so in
particular to the the word Co currents
distributions seem to be a bit more
evenly spread out which is what you
might expect without the retweet
amplification so here's one example
about hurricane Florence which was
making its way up the coast at the time
and another thing of local interest I'm
very close race between Dan Cohen Laurie
Troy hen so just to be clear up until
now I've only described the methodology
for coming up with the word clusters so
really what we've got is this so how do
we go from the cluster definition on the
Left who's saying that you can can can
read on the right and remember that the
downstream application here is an is an
overview page that a user should be able
to quickly scan and then launch into
other modes of discovery we could just
leave it at the keyboards but it turns
out that there's actually a substantial
literature on what are called
summarization techniques and
summarization involves generating some
human readable form of the word clusters
and the the truly ambitious try to
generate grammatically correct new
sentences that describe the cluster but
we ought to instead of picking out just
best suite that we can summarize so
summarization is an open and active area
of research for members in the lab but
unfortunately there isn't a single
accepted way for people to do it and so
we went with something that's quick and
dirty instead it's crude but I would say
the results are 60% of the time are
decent ok so well what we do is for each
classroom we look for the tweet that is
closest by some measure of the
collection of the words and the rub then
is to define what it means for tweet to
be close to a cluster and for this we
turn to cosine similarity which is a
pretty standard technique cosine
similarity says something like this so
imagine that you've got two points in
space and you want to know how close to
each other they are one way to tell is
to draw two lines one from the center of
space to the first point and then one
from the center space to the second
point and then you look at the angle
between those two if the angle is zero
right which means that the cosine is one
then you say that those two points are
similar and if the angle is ninety or
cosine of zero then they and they're
perpendicular to each other then they're
very different so though though all of
this is happening in a very high
dimensional space we can better
illustrate this just in two dimensions
so a particular cluster might be defined
by the words Kotra hand-recount which
sits somewhere in space and in some
other tweet also sits in space and his
location is defined by the words in a
tweet body and the similarity measure
between the two is the angle in green
between those two points so the closer
the angle to zero the more similar those
two points are what we do then is we
take the word clusters and we put them
into in you know in in this space where
each of the words is one dimension and
then we take all of the tweets and we
calculate the cosine similarity against
each cluster and a clusters
representative tweet is the one that has
the highest cosine similarity so it's a
it's brute force but it worked well
enough to give our users a sense of what
the cluster is about a neat kind of a
side effect of having these these
definitions of the clusters then is
after we discover some cluster we can
then apply it going backwards in time
which we've we've we've kind of done in
research but we haven't actually put
into the product
quite yet so right so we can ask the
question okay when did this event
actually start to - to gain steam and we
do that using a cosine similarity one of
the difficulties in creating an
algorithm like this is that it's um it's
really unclear how we're supposed to
evaluate the quality of the results we
don't even know how to precisely define
an event right are two different traffic
slowdowns different events or you know
slow traffic in general is that just one
event when Pressley one we had a case
where the algorithm started finding
multiple viewpoints on the same event
this is a good thing if you're looking
for multiple takes on Presley's win or
the bad thing if you think of it all as
one you knows one thing so it's unclear
exactly how to resolve this in a way
that fits all use cases one thing that's
really important to note though is that
with the graph size reduction techniques
levain runs really fast so calculating
these clusters on a day's worth of
tweets of for single city takes two to
three seconds on a single core levain
speed was one of the primary motivations
here for going down this route at two to
three seconds for calculating the events
we can actually have the user
interactively tell us what granularity
they want the clusters and so this is
the thing that we're going to build into
you know our product in the future and
this the speed of the vania is is a huge
plus but but also the fact that we don't
have to set a fixed K number of topics
right like and all the other techniques
you you have to have some notion
beforehand of how many things you're
trying to discover so you know so this
is a this this relieves us of you know
of that pressure and and by using words
as nodes in the graph we get to generate
interprete both topics in the same way
that Lda does okay so so what's next so
I've I've mentioned a few times now that
the cluster definitions consists of
words that are mutually exclusive this
seems to not be an issue in practice so
like I said evaluation is it's hard so
one thing that we'll be looking into is
using a community detection algorithm
that can generate overlapping committees
conductance so the standard right now is
to optimize its optimized modularity
but modularity suffers from a tendency
to ignore very small clusters there are
other measures that might be better if
we really want to be able to focus on on
local stories which maybe have smaller
you know smaller size clusters so
conducted since one way and then the
third thing is that we're going to work
on a but better evaluation techniques so
that we can tune the hyper parameters a
bit more levain and the version of the
vein that we're using has one resolution
parameter which I didn't I didn't talk
about so there's one there's one thing
to tune there and we had this notion
that we we we we'd want to be able to
minimize the number of clusters so that
maximizes the amount of diversity in the
clusters so in other projects in the lab
we'd previously used information
theoretic methods to do this so we might
go with that strategy again so you can
think of diversity in a cluster similar
to diversity in you know an ecology so
what's the variety of species in some
ecosystem compared to the size of you
know of other populations so there are
quantitative ways for doing this such as
Simpsons index and Shannon entropy rudy
singh word noise is a goal to there are
lots of words that don't produce sexual
information but are not simply stop
words so here we've discovered some
existing work on using KO currents where
distributions to eliminate low
information words the rough intuition
here is that you can take a distribution
of words from a really big set let's say
an entire month worth of tweets and then
the distribution from from a day worth
of tweets and you subtract out the month
distribution and you get like the
unusual words for that day we use a
technique like this in a different part
of the product but it's definitely worth
trying to import that over here we're
still working on tuning the algorithm
for talk radio so our ability to segment
sentences through our speech recognizer
isn't great and also spoken word is much
more fluid and less perfunctory than
tweets so as a result the words in the
graph tend to have higher branching
factors and produced larger and less
meaningful clusters
one of the things that comes out of our
talk radio clustering pretty
consistently is it's a cluster of it's a
class of Liberty Mutual ads because I
guess they advertise on talk radio a lot
anyways yeah so I'm you know so I'm
optimistic that we'll figure this one
out
so another network approach suggested by
some researchers is to set up bipartite
graphs yeah so this is a neat idea so so
the basic idea is that you have a graph
where you have a bunch of tweets on the
left and then a bunch of words that they
use on the right with with the edges
between them and you look for
collections of words that form
communities of tweets the analogy is
this like so you know suppose you were
to have a bunch of Twitter accounts on
the left and then a bunch of famous
Twitter accounts on the right you can
pick out who the movie stars are from
the famous a clown uh from the famous
accounts because people on the Left tend
to follow them in droves even if the
movie stars themselves don't follow each
other and there are Network methods for
figuring out these bipartite matches and
then finally as I mentioned before we'll
be looking at moving the hyper parameter
directly into the user interface if we
can keep the algorithm fast then we can
give more tunable control to the user
and perhaps bypass some of these
evaluation problems alright so lastly I
want to leave you with a reckless idea
you know is something that's been
percolating in my mind but is completely
on you know completely unsubstantiated
and probably wrong we've you know we've
we've gotten a lot of press recently do
two words avec on using algebraic ways
to do a lot of this language analysis
right so you know we use these big
clusters to train neural nets to put the
words into the vector space or in the
case of LD a we think about the words
you know as these these topics is bags
with statistical properties the network
analysis approach seems more right to me
for some reason because of the physical
world which must tie into how we learn
language and you know and our brains are
networks and we live in social networks
they're better modeled as mathematical
networks rather than vector spaces so
like in the allegory of the cave like I
you know I think of vector spaces and
statistics as like the shadows on the
wall projecting some distorted but you
know but still useful form of reality
but that networks are closer closer form
to the essence of this
yeah so so that's all I got
there's a link here to some academic
reference material the the three papers
that inspired this work if you have any
questions about the talk or quarter Cove
you can feel free to other Grammy and
chat or hiring so if you want to do this
kind of interesting computational work
for social causes come find me
especially if you're not a data
scientist I have an endless supply of
batty researchers at my disposal so I
need the non batty non researchers you
can find me on twitter spouting about
this stuff and I don't I don't have a
SoundCloud but I do have a tiny letter
so alright thanks
[Applause]